[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
the grey train robbery der große Postzug
Raub macht 1963 weltweit Schlagzeilen
eine Räuberbande bringt den Zug von
Glasgow nach London zum Stehen
überwältigt die Beamten darin und
entkommt mit 2,6 Millionen Pfund das
wären heute umgerechnet mehr als 60
Millionen Euro ist eine Menge die Bande
schafft es auch noch sich selbst und die
Beute auf einem Hof in der Nähe des
Tatorts in Sicherheit zu bringen aber
dann geht nach und nach alles schief
beim überstürzten Aufbruch hinterlassen
die Männer jede Menge Spuren und dann
machen Sie einen Fehler nach dem anderen
willkommen zum zweiten Teil dieser
weltberühmten Geschichte ich bin Toni
Haier und mit mir ist wie immer der
Liebe mit mir hallo Mirko halli Hallo
Toni schönen guten Tag an alle da
draußen
der erste Posträuber der gravierende
Fehlleistungen produziert ist Roger
cordray er macht nämlich die Witwe eines
Polizisten misstrauisch als er bei ihr
eine Garage mietet und für mehrere
Monate im Voraus mit gebrauchten 10
Schilling scheinen bezahlt na sie dürfte
ihren verstorbenen Mann im Himmel sehr
stolz gemacht haben auf jeden Fall kippt
die Bande jetzt schnell wie eine Reihe
Dominosteine Fingerabdrücke
Zeugenaussagen Widersprüche in Verhören
die führen bin kurzer Zeit zu den
Festnahmen der Männer am 20 Januar 1964
beginnt der Prozess gegen 8
Bandenmitglieder und mehrere Helfer der
Prozess ist eine riesen Sensation denn
der Post zu grob ist seit Monaten das
Gesprächsthema viele sehen in den
Räubern keine Verbrecher sondern Helden
genau weil sie ist eben dem
Establishment mal so richtig gezeigt
haben moderne Robin Hood sozusagen oder
Robin
Robin Hoodies Robin Hoodies gefällt mir
zack Idee gedroppt für den
Bekleidungsmarkt
ja das ist eine gute Idee aber ist ja
auch egal und der Vergleich mit den
legendären Straßenräubern der hinkt
sowieso ein bisschen weil die zugräber
überhaupt nicht daran gedacht haben die
Beute an die Armen zu verteilen sie sind
beliebt sie sind berühmt und sie werden
bewundert und das bis heute tja und
genau das wurmt die Richter und die
Staatsanwaltschaft natürlich mächtig sie
statuiert ein Exempel und verknackt die
Täter zu den höchstmöglichen Strafen und
auch einige Helfer die eigentlich nur
kleine Delikte begangen haben
größtenteils ohne zu wissen an was sie
da eigentlich beteiligt sind für sieben
der gefassten Räuber lautet das Urteil
30 Jahre einer kann dank seines Anwalt
den Fängen der Justiz entkommen denn
genau genommen waren all die
Fingerabdrücke im versteckt kein Beweis
für eine Beteiligung an der Tat sondern
nur dafür dass die Angeklagten sich zu
irgendeinem Zeitpunkt eben dort
aufgehalten und Monopoly gespielt hatten
zwei Angeklagte müssen später vom
Vorwurf des Raubes freigesprochen werden
bei einem von ihnen William Bowl musste
man später sogar einen justizirtum
zugeben und eine Entschuldigung
aussprechen die kam aber leider zu spät
denn William starb 1970 im Gefängnis ein
Krebs allerdings kann nur ein geringer
Teil der Beute sichergestellt werden bis
heute ist der Verbleib des größtenteils
unklar trat sie ihr Reynold wurde erst
1968 verhaftet da waren zwei der
Verurteilten schon wieder auf freiem Fuß
ja so kann man es ausdrücken schon 1964
Flut Charlie Wilson aus dem Gefängnis
ein dreiköpfiges Team war in das Winston
green Gefängnis in Birmingham
eingebrochen und hatte ihn befreit
dieses Team wurde nie geschnappt Wilson
selbst ging's Gotland 1968 kurz nach
Reynolds in die Fänge und dann im Juli
1965 gelang dem legendärsten der
legendären oder die Flucht Rani Biggs ja
und sein Legenden Status beruht vor
allem auf genau dieser Flucht und die
ist eine ziemlich hemdärmlige
Angelegenheit nichts mit auf den Rücken
tätowierten ausbruchsplänen und
Hubschraubern und tollen Gadgets nicht
mal eine popelige im Kuchen versteckte
Pfeile oder so alles was es braucht sind
ein paar Mitgefangene die beim Ausgang
im Hof der Haftanstalt mal eben kurz die
Wächter ablenken und eine Strickleiter
die Komplizen von außen über die
Gefängnismauer werfen das ist echt wie
im Cartoon oder in so einem schlechten
Krimi aber gut damals ging sowas
offenbar noch ja vielleicht ist es genau
das wenn die Leute immer von denen guten
alten Zeiten sprechen
weißt du noch damals als mit einem
Handschuhen einer Batterie einen Zug
anhalten und mit einer Strickleiter aus
dem Gefängnis ausbrechen konnte ich
glaube dass die gute alte Zeit genau
diese gute alte Zeit für Ronny beginnt
auf jeden Fall jetzt so etwas wie ein
zweites Leben blicken wir kurz auf das
erste zurück Ronald Biggs Jahrgang 1929
war Zimmermann in red Hill im Süden
Englands er hatte mit seiner Frau Kamin
rufen zwei Söhne und schon vor dem
großen Postraub beginnt er eine
kriminelle Karriere und verübt mit einer
Bande namens Fulham Boys einige
Überfälle und Einbrüche nach dem Postzug
Raub und nach seiner Flucht fährt er
nach Paris und unterzieht sein
weltberühmtes verbrechergesicht einer
plastischen Operation die gründlich
schief geht
ja aber nicht so wie man sich das jetzt
vorstellt er wickelt die Bandagen ab und
darunter kommt ein schrecklich
entstelltes Gesicht zum Vorschein nee
also so war das nicht mit schiefgehen
ist gemeint dass er danach noch ziemlich
genau so aussieht wie vorher oh mein
Gott einmal mit Profis arbeiten
seine weitere Flucht führt Bix unter
anderem nach Australien und schließlich
1970 nach Brasilien diese Etappe
markiert endgültig den Bruch mit seinem
früheren Leben denn Frau und Söhne lässt
Bix zurück Brasilien hatte unter anderem
deshalb ausgesucht weil es keinen
auslieferungsvertrag mit Großbritannien
hat gut für ihn denn 1974 wird er
gefunden von Colin McKenzie einem
Reporter des Daily Express und kurz
darauf steht natürlich auch Scotland
Yard auf der Matte der Beamte der die
Geschichte mit Bix klar machen soll
heißt Jack Slipper er reist nach Rio und
überrascht Bix im Hotel mit den Worten
hey Ronny lange nicht gesehen aber eine
Verhaftung bleibt Slipper verwehrt und
zwar aus zwei Gründen England und
Brasilien können sich nicht auf den
gegenseitigen Austausch von Kriminellen
einigen obwohl sowas auch ohne ein
grundsätzliches Abkommen ginge und
zweitens wird Bix gerade Vater
er ist mit der Stripperin Raimunda de
Castro zusammen und die erwartet ein
Kind von ihm und das brasilianische
Recht verbietet ausdrücklich die
Auslieferung eines Elternteils eines
brasilianischen Kindes juristisch hat
bics also Glück aber ansonsten läuft
sein Leben anders als man es nach einem
Raub mit Millionen Beute erwarten würde
es ist nicht ganz klar ob er seinen
Anteil schnell aufgebraucht hat oder
nicht auf der Flucht mitnehmen konnte er
muss jedenfalls einiges für seinen
Lebensunterhalt tun und nachdem er nun
einmal enttarnt ist lebt er vor allem
von seinem Ruhm Touristen lassen sich
mit ihm fotografieren er gibt Autogramme
und macht Musik normalerweise Jazz doch
berühmt werden seine Ausflüge ins
punksorge
1978 nimmt der zwei Songs mit den Sex
Pistols auf von denen einer no one ist
innocent niemand ist unschuldig es ist
auf Platz sieben in den ukshirt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und der Text der ist echt eine grobe
Sache wie bei Gott save the Queen
beginnt jede Strophe mit God Safe und
listet dann Verbrecher auf wie zum
Beispiel den Nazi Martin Bormann oder
den afrikanischen Diktator Idi Amin und
eben Ronny Biggs die Band erklärt das so
dass Gott eben auch böse Menschen lieb
habe naja
1991 steht Ronnie Biggs dann mit den
Toten Hosen im Studio da hören wir jetzt
auch mal ganz kurz rein
[Musik]
in diesem Text geht es letztendlich um
eine Würdigung des Punkrock selbst mit
Zeilen wie
punkweinsaufgelage Punk war eine
Schlägerei Punk war in der Nase bohren
und das Mittagessen in den Müll werfen
da bleibt die Frage worin Ronnie biGs
schlechter war im lokführen oder beim
Singen
1997 schließen Großbritannien und
Brasilien schließlich doch noch ein
Auslieferungsabkommen
abwegs erklärt sich freiwillig bereit in
seiner Heimat zurückzukehren und seine
Strafe abzusitzen 2001 36 Jahren nach
seinem Ausbruch fliegt er mit einem von
der Zeitung und das Tannen bezahlten
Privatjet nach Hause und wird bei der
Ankunft festgenommen zu diesem Zeitpunkt
ist Bix 72 Jahre alt und schwer krank
das ist abzusehen dass er wohl kaum die
28 Jahre Rest Strafe absetzen wird
2009 wird Biggs aus humanitären Gründen
entlassen 2013 stirbt er in einem
Pflegeheim Weltraum erlangte aber auch
ein weiterer Mittäter des großen
postraums Ronald Christopher Edwards
Spitzname basta Edwards war zwei Jahre
jünger als Biggs war Boxer und Nachtclub
Besitzer ihm erging es nach dem Raub
anders als Pics aber letztlich nicht
viel besser Edwards konnte mit seiner
Frau June und Tochter Nicolette nach
Mexiko fliehen und dort in Acapulco in
Saus und Braus leben er traf dort auch
seine Komplizen Reynolds und Wilson aber
das Geld war schnell verpasst und was da
litt unter schrecklichem Heimweh also
verhandelte er 1966 über seine Rückkehr
nach England er wurde verhaftet und zu
15 Jahren Gefängnis verurteilt nach der
vorzeitigen Entlassung im Jahr 1975
betrieb er einen Blumenstand am Londoner
Bahnhof Waterloo das klingt wirklich
harmlos und nach einem Achtung Wortwitz
blumigen Happy End aber 1994 erhängte
basta Edward sich im Vollrausch an einem
Stahlbalken in dieser Zeit soll es auch
betrugsermittlungen gegen ihn gegeben
haben immerhin war im sechs Jahre vorher
ein Denkmal gesetzt worden sein Leben
wurde mit dem Popsänger Phil Collins der
Hauptrolle verfilmt und den kitschigen
Titelsong kann man bis heute regelmäßig
im Radio hören
[Musik]
ja als Legenden werden sie weiterleben
Ronnie biGs und Buster Edwards und der
große Zug Raub wird noch unzählige Filme
Serien und Songs inspirieren und
meistens werden die Gangster darin etwas
genialer netter und Robin hoodyga
dargestellt werden als sie es wohl
tatsächlich waren und das war's für
heute danke fürs zuhören wenn euch diese
Folge gefallen hat dann bewertet uns
doch z.B gerne bei Spotify oder Apple
Podcast oder wo immer ihr uns hört und
denkt dran die Glocke zu aktivieren das
supportet uns und wir freuen uns riesig
darüber und damit bis zum nächsten mal
euer Mirko und eure Toni